Hi, welcome back.
In this class, we'll be exploring
Blueprint and Modeling Tools
for managing assets in Unreal.
Let's get right into it.
In Unreal, a Blueprint class
defines the type of actor that you can place into your scene as instances.
Editing that Blueprint class will update
every instance of it in our project, and that's really handy.
There are various types of Blueprints you can create.
Based on their parent classes,
they will inherit different kinds of properties.
Today, we're going to be using the Actor class type,
which is an object that can be easily placed in the world.
A Blueprint Actor specifically can hold various components in it,
like static mesh components, collision components,
audio components, and more.
These components define the actor's appearance,
behavior, and how it interacts with the world.
This all comes quite useful to us,
because a Blueprint Actor will basically be a basket
to which we will add all the eggs we'd like.
With the click of a button,
we could easily swap the eggs with cubes,
as well as change their appearance if we wanted to.
Thus, changes would be applied not only to the Blueprint Actor,
but also to all the instances of it in our Maps.
I know this whole Blueprint-Majorowska concept
can feel quite abstract at the beginning.
Let's jump into the Engine and see it in action.
I want to keep things simple for this video,
so I'm just going to go under File, New Level,
and then Create a Basic Level.
Down here, we can just click on the Player Start and delete it,
because we're not going to be using it today.
Then up here in the Quick Ad menu,
we can go under Shapes and create a Simple Cube.
If we wanted to add this Simple Cube to a Blueprint,
we could just click on this Blueprint button up here,
and then convert the selection to a Blueprint class.
You can choose different creation methods.
The one that I find the most modular
is the Harvest Component one.
We can choose the parent class to be whatever we want.
We can also choose it to be an Actor,
but for now, I'm going to keep it to Static Mesh Actor.
The parent class of this Blueprint will be Static Mesh Actor.
The Blueprint name, I'm going to assign it to BP underscore cube,
and then I'm going to just save it under the Blueprints folder up here.
All right, so this will open my default BP cube,
and I'm just going to dock it up here.
So you can see up here that we have two different components
assigned to our Blueprint,
and the third one is the Static Mesh Component
with our cube assigned to it.
Up here, you can find the parent class of this Blueprint,
which is the Static Mesh Actor.
Now, if we wanted to, we could just move this cube around.
We could change this to a different mesh,
and we could also change the material assigned to it.
But first, I want to show you how to do things a little bit differently,
because if we go back to our map,
we can see that since the parent class of this BP cube
is a Static Mesh Actor,
its thumbnail up here is the one of a Static Mesh,
which can be a little bit confusing,
because it's not a Static Mesh, it's actually a Blueprint.
And if you simply click on it,
it looks as if there is no Static Mesh assigned to it,
and that's simply because we selected the parent of the class,
not the single component.
So if we click on Static Mesh Component 1,
we'll get access to the single component,
and we would be able to change it if we wanted to.
Since this method can be a little bit confusing,
I'm going to show you a different one.
So let's right-click in the Content Browser,
and then create a Blueprint class.
We can choose Actor as Parent Class,
and then we're going to call this BP cube Actor.
Now, you can already see from the thumbnail up here
that those two Blueprints have two different Parent Classes.
The one of the Actor usually has this little sphere
with a plane underneath it.
So let's double-click on it to open it up,
and you can see that it's completely empty.
That's because we haven't added any components to it.
So if we go here on the left, we can click on Add,
and then Static Mesh.
And if we click on our Static Mesh,
we can go into the Details,
and then choose any Static Mesh Actor we want to down here,
and I'm just going to choose the cube.
All right.
Now that I've made my changes to the Blueprint,
I want to make sure to Compile.
You need to always compile your Blueprints,
and then I'm just going to Save.
Now, if I go back to my map,
and then I drag and drop this BPQ Actor
into the Scene, it will be spawned in my map.
Now, let's say we wanted to apply more changes
to this Blueprint container.
So I'm just going to go right into it,
and then I'm going to be adding a new Static Mesh.
And if you, like me, had the cube Static Mesh Component
selected and then clicked on Add,
and then added a new Static Mesh,
you might have added a child of this Static Mesh Component.
I'll show you what I mean.
So if I click on Static Mesh 1,
which is the second Static Mesh we created,
and then add a different Static Mesh to it, like a cone,
you will see that we can move this cone independently.
But then if I click on the first Static Mesh,
which is supposed to be the parent,
and then I move it around, the cube will go with it.
That's because the cone is attached to it.
But if I just drag and drop it on top of it,
it will be side by side.
So I could move the cube independently of the cone.
Okay, let's compile and save these changes,
and then go back to our map,
and you can see that the changes were immediately applied to our map.
And if I alt and drag onto the gizmo,
I could duplicate this Blueprint instance,
and I could do it as many times if I want.
Now, if I go back to my Blueprint cube actor,
I could assign a different material to this,
like a basic yellow material to the cone,
and then a basic red material to the cube.
I would compile and save,
and if I go back to my map,
you can see that the changes were applied to all of them.
Now, the ones you see here are instances of the Blueprint actor.
So the Blueprint actor, we can say it's the father
of all these different children.
If I wanted to, I could apply individual changes to each one of them.
If I double click on a Blueprint actor,
I get access to their individual components.
So this means that I could just move this cube around and the cone,
and I could even just change the whole static mesh assigned to it
if I wanted to, as well as the material.
But these changes would just be applied to this individual instance,
and they won't actually appear in my Blueprint actor,
that's because the Blueprint actor is the father,
and those are the children.
Let's jump back into the slides to take a look at modeling tools
and how to use them.
Now, modeling tools lets us create, sculpt,
and edit 3D geometry directly in Unreal Engine.
But before diving into them any further,
we need to make sure that the modeling tools editor mode plugin
is enabled in our project.
The other two that you see here in the slide
don't really matter for what we're going to be doing today,
so the modeling tools editor mode would suffice.
Make sure to restart the engine after you enable the plugin.
So today, we're going to keep it quite simple
and we're just going to learn how to adjust pivot points
on our static mesh actors using the modeling tools.
So let's jump into the engine and learn how to do that.
Okay, first of all, I'm just going to go file, new level,
and create another basic map just to keep it simple.
And we don't need to save these changes.
Then I'm just going to be deleting my player start.
And in this map, we just want to add a mega scan asset,
any asset would do.
So I'm just going to choose a dead tree.
And then I'm going to be importing it into my map.
Now, if our aim for today were to be changing the pivot
of this mesh temporarily, we could simply do it
by pressing alt on our keyboard and then middle mouse button
on our mesh or anywhere else where we wanted our pivot
to be positioned.
So I'm just going to be setting it there.
And then if I were to perform a transform action,
so just rotate scale or move this object,
it would be performed from this pivot point.
Now, since that's at temporary position,
the pivot point would immediately snap back
to its original position.
And now I'm just going to reset the location
and rotation to its original values.
And if you wanted that temporary pivot to actually stick
and be permanently replaced, then you would need to again,
press alt on the keyboard and middle mouse button
to whatever you want it to be positioned.
And then right click on the mesh, pivot and set as pivot offset.
Now, even if we perform any changes to the position
of this mesh or rotated it around, as well as clicking away
and then back on the tree, the pivot would stay as it was.
And if you wanted to reset it, you could just right click
on the tree, pivot and reset pivot offset.
And now we'll go back to its original position.
Now, this method of changing the pivot position
is not very precise and it's a little bit finicky,
as you could see.
So let's take a look at how to achieve this
using the modeling tools instead.
Now, you got to be careful.
And before you apply any changes to a static mesh actor
in your map using the modeling tools,
you want to make sure to duplicate it first
in the content browser.
This might sound a little unintuitive
based on the behavior we just saw
using the blueprint actors
because modeling tools actually work the opposite.
Basically, any changes you apply to a static mesh actor
using the modeling tools in your map
is also going to be applied to the static mesh asset itself,
the one we have here in the content browser.
So these changes won't just stick to our map only,
but to our entire project.
Meaning that if we use this static tree mesh
into a different scene within our project
and we edited it here into this map using the modeling tools,
those changes will be applied to the three
in the other scenes too.
So that's why it's extremely important
to duplicate the asset you'd like to change
in the content browser first.
So let's do that.
I'm going to right click on the SMDat tree
and then duplicate it.
Now I'm just going to call it that tree changed.
And then with the dat tree,
a static mesh actor selected into my map,
I'm just going to go into the details panel
and then click on this little button down here
to use the selected asset
that we have in the content browser.
As assigned mesh to this actor.
Now nothing will change in your map
because this is simply a duplicate of the original tree.
But this will make sure that any changes
that we apply on this dat tree
will just be applied to this changed pivot asset
and not to the original one that we also used
in the other map.
Now let's switch our mode from selection mode
to modeling mode.
And then under the XForm section,
you can see the edit pivot tool.
And here you want to make sure that you apply the changes
to all the LODs.
This is really important.
And you can also snap drag the position of the pivot
or snap drag the rotation of the pivot
if you needed to.
And then this box position will basically
be based on the bounding box of the tree.
And I could choose to position the pivot
at the center of the bounding box at the bottom,
the top, the left, the right, the back, the front,
and the world origin.
I'm going to stick to center for now.
And then apply my changes.
OK, so this will be a permanent change,
meaning that if I drag out of this tree
to create a different instance of it,
the pivot position will stay the same
as well as if I drag another instance of it
from the content browser directly into my map,
the pivot point would be the one that we just changed.
If we import the 01, meaning the original tree,
you will see that the pivot point would be
in a different position.
So there are a lot of other tools here
you can use to deform or edit your mesh
with the modeling tools,
but that's going to be it for today's class.
But you're nice, so I'll give you a quick tip nonetheless.
If you're going to apply drastic modeling changes
to any asset, make sure to go under Edit Project Settings.
And then in the search bar, type Enable,
Raytracing, while editing, and you want to turn this on.
This will prevent weird artifacts to appear
in your viewport while you're editing your assets.
Then also, if you aim to deform the shape of your mesh,
it might be good to check out once you're done
that your UVs are still correctly tiling on your object
and reproject them if necessary.
You can find the UV Editor under More and UVs up here.
But luckily for today,
we just wanted to change the pivot position of our mesh,
so no drastic changes on your resin for now.
I hope this gave you a good glimpse at modeling tools
and how to use them in your project.
Let's go back to our slides to conclude this video.
So that was it for this class,
but you can find some additional documentation at this link
if you're interested in further extending your knowledge
in blueprint assets and modeling tools.
I'd also encourage you, as usual, to take a look at our courses
focused on in-editor modeling tools
to learn more about the specific set of tools
in the engine.
Thanks for sticking around, and in the upcoming lesson,
we will look into level editing,
as well as the stage monitor and level snapshots.
I'll see you there. Bye.